there's so many people when they haven't
run a business they think that again
doesn't matter what the idea is they
have to somehow go out and get
investment or a loan or something like
that that's what I was thinking cuz like
Dragon's Den and stuff you know I follow
St B's podcast I saw he was on Dragon's
Den and I'm like you got to get that
100K investment before you start yeah
and it's BS it's a complete
misconception because in any business
there is a version which you can start
from the ground up with no Capital you
can just do something towards anything
doesn't matter you can go and register a
domain name you can go and set up a
social media like Twitter account all
these things that you can do for free
yet people sit there and go well I can't
get a loan I've got ccj against me I
can't get a loan so therefore I can't
start a business well you're no better
off if you take literally no steps
towards whatever your goal is so people
just end up
procrastinating